oh good it smells like rubber
this one looks and feels like it's not
gonna taste good there's like peanut
butter in your mouth that's me and a few
hungry co-workers tasting 13 different
veggie burgers nope nope it tastes like
broccoli today you can find the veggie
burgers pretty much everywhere and some
brands are even trying to give real beef
a run for its money but how do they all
stack up and are they really that much
healthier than the real thing that's
what I set out to discover
let's go hunt some veggie burgers
in grocery stores
I found your typical brands like Boca
and morning star and at fast-food chains
I picked up the impossible burger and
the beyond burger and after that there
was nothing left to do but eat and rank
which burgers reigned supreme spoiler
that brand wasn't a favorite in the end
six volunteers including me tasted all
13 veggie burgers plus one real beef
burger which I tossed in for good
measure
we scored each burger on its overall
look smell taste and texture and on how
it compared to a real beef burger that's
like what's in lose fell apart overall
the veggie burgers well they weren't
very popular but one did stand out the
impossible burger from Burger King with
a patty made from plants no beef get it
while it lasts
this is the best one in life always I
thought we were gonna be sad this cold
yeah it got a near-perfect score in the
first category it even beat out the beef
burger and it was just shy of the beef
burger in the second one which makes
sense because you know beef should win
in a category about how meat like
something is the only other veggie
burger that came close in either
category was Gardein but as you can see
it was still several points away from
impossible and there was something else
I noticed many of the low scoring
burgers were knocked for smelling and
tasting artificial No I taste chemicals
this tastes like plastic like up in the
back of your palate and I can't get past
that it's all like Clorox
and that got me thinking are these
burgers actually good for you
after all eating healthy is one of the
main reasons why people avoid red meat
so I asked a registered dietician today
we're gonna talk about veggie burgers so
I thought I was appropriate that we
would get one of the new impossible
burgers from Burger King I don't
regularly eat Burger King or at least I
don't want anyone to know that I reckon
I was scolded for making a dietician he
fast food we got into it hmm
from a health point of view what what
should you consider if it's gonna be the
source of protein it you definitely want
to look at the protein content she said
to shoot for fifteen to thirty grams of
protein per veggie burger so how did our
burgers measure up let's take a look as
you can see a lot of them had plenty of
protein like dr. Prager 's 28 grams
that's way more than even the beef
burger and while a lot of veggie burger
protein comes from soy Moskovitz said
that's not a problem
now the consensus is pretty much that
not only a soy not bad for you but it
actually can fight off cancer it could
be really good for your heart and it as
a vegetarian and definitely as a vegan
it's a really good source of complete
protein you should also be mindful of
sodium the average healthy adult should
try to keep it under 2,300 milligrams of
sodium per day so if the veggie burger
is clocking in at over 600 700
milligrams of salt you know that's also
something to consider
now all thirteen veggie burgers did have
more sodium than the beef patty but they
were still well below that 600 milligram
mark and another nutrient to look out
for is saturated fat especially if you
have a history of cluster high
cholesterol or any sort of heart disease
if you can find one that has like less
than 2 or 3 grams of saturated fat that
would be great
here's where the impossible and Beyond
burger stood out unlike most of the
other veggie burgers they had a similar
amount of saturated fat as beef and
that's at least partly why they taste so
much like the real thing but there's one
type of fat that really sets veggie
burgers apart from real beef and that's
trans fat the
thing you'll ever hear dietitian say
don't eat ever is trans fat you know
everything in moderation
except for trans fat it increases your
bed LDL cholesterol and it decreases
your good HDL cholesterol so there's
actually good reason to believe that
veggie burgers are healthier than meat
especially considering that red meat has
been linked to some forms of cancer but
that doesn't mean veggie burgers are
healthy in general case in point
remember that chemical taste I taste
chemicals it might have something to do
with the dozens of ingredients added to
these burgers to make them taste like a
beef patty it has a ton of ingredients
you know that's probably an issue and a
lot of if a lot of those things you a
five-year-old can't pronounce then
that's even more of an issue I mean I
can't even pronounce these and how will
you prepare that burger also matters are
you putting cheese on it are you putting
a ton of ketchup and mayonnaise are you
having it on a white bun you know that's
also something you want to consider
in other words fast food is fast food it
is interesting because like I look at
this burger and I'm like I am healthier
than the person next to me eating like
this with meat yes it might be healthier
but if you're eating this every day and
the guy next to you is eating that beef
burger once a month who's really
healthier now of course there are
reasons other than personal health to
choose veggie burgers they have a
smaller environmental footprint than
beef for example and no cows were killed
to make them and if you are concerned
about your health
just look for burgers with a short list
of ingredients or better yet make them
yourself I eat almost everything that's
just terrible